et on va plus loin avec ici même à mes
côtés il y a l'imam directeur du mensuel
Afrique Magazine bonjour ziade soir
Afrique Magazine qui fait ça une un pour
ces deux mois toujours sur la forêt
deuxième poumon de l'humanité derrière
l'Amazonie autre souci de l'époque
exactement le changement le dérèglement
climatique avec cette forêt donc dernier
poumon de la planète on parle notamment
à bien sûr de la République démocratique
du Congo et puis également DJ Snake que
vous avez rencontré et puis Bruno
Darroux chroniqueur international ici
même à France 24 bonjour Bruno bonjour
Raphaël geste désespéré d'un pays en
passe de perdre la guerre comme la firme
certains Européens ou menaces réelles de
recourir à l'arme nucléaire comme on le
fera ouvertement du côté de Washington
où l'on dit prendre au sérieux la menace
agitée en début de journée par Vladimir
Poutine elle est réactions évidemment
s'enchaînent à la tribune de l'ONU
notamment et forcée de le constater
devant la fuite en avant de la Russie le
monde se perd en conjecture écoutez ce
que déclarait le numéro un russe
le but de l'Occident est d'affaiblir de
diviser et finalement de détruire notre
pays ils disent clairement qu'en 1991
ils ont réussi à diviser l'Union
soviétique et qu'il est maintenant temps
de faire de même avec la Russie
et si l'intégrité territoriale de notre
pays est menacé nous utiliserons sans
aucun doute tous les moyens à notre
disposition pour protéger la Russie et
notre peuple ce n'est pas du bluff si
on répond à annonce déjà une
mobilisation partielle seront appelées
les réservistes et les citoyens russes
disposant d'une spécialité militaire le
Kremlin compte sur 300 000 hommes mais
25 millions de Russes en âge de
combattre ce sont déjà potentiellement
concernés du moins un certain nombre qui
qui manifestent à Moscou tente de
quitter le pays Bruno oui il y a aussi
apparemment des manifestations à
Saint-Pétersbourg donc un peu retour
quand même des manifestations on se
souvient qu'il y en avait eu au tout
premier jour de la guerre de l'opération
militaire spécial comme Vladimir Poutine
continue à le dire même si ça devient
encore plus fictionnel aujourd'hui et
bien retour de ces manifestations
notamment de parents il y a eu des
slogans
savent of children sauver la vie de nos
enfants dont visiblement c'est une
mesure qui passe mal Vladimir Poutine le
savait sans doute c'est pour ça qu'il
n'a annoncé que la mobilisation
partielle celle des réservistes et
celles effectivement de de soldats ayant
une compétence mais visiblement ça
inquiète beaucoup plus de monde à
travers d'autres pays et surtout et bien
beaucoup de ces réservistes n'ont
absolument pas envie d'aller mourir en
Ukraine et puis autre chose ça souligne
aussi la très grande difficulté que
traverse actuellement l'armée russe en
Ukraine parce que bien sûr si la lumière
Poutine ordonne cette mobilisation
partielle c'est qu'il commence tout
simplement à manquer d'effectifs pour
combattre en Ukraine c'est le moment de
vérité pour Poutine il y a le peuple
russe non plus seulement les militaires
comme c'était le cas jusqu'à présent
mais les civils vont-ils risquer leur
vie au service de son ambition de mettre
au pas l'Ukraine
c'est clairement un moment de crise
parce que on
reconnaît pas un leader sur de lui
confiant dans sa guerre confiant dans
ses objectifs on d'abord il y a cette
espèce de mystère du discours qui devait
avoir lieu hier soir qui était annoncé
et puis qui a été reporté donc on sent
bien que à l'intérieur de la machine
Kremlin il y a visiblement des tensions
je pense aussi que on mesure aujourd'hui
de manière plus directe la baffe qui a
été la bataille de
la bataille de début septembre et le
recul de 1500 km la désorganisation
complète de cette armée qui était
supposée
être une des armées les plus fortes du
monde donc il y a visiblement un moment
de crise qui doit se doubler d'un moment
de crise politique parce que on sait pas
comment ça s'agite autour de lui je
pense pas que les libéraux représentent
une force réelle d'abord les trois
quarts sont en tôle ou ou sont expatriés
ou ailleurs en Europe donc je pense que
le danger aussi pour le régime Poutine
peut venir de sa tomates de gens qui
inondent la télévision russe de discours
enflammés faut utiliser l'arme nucléaire
faut les bombarder faut les raser faut
raser longues faut raser Paris et donc
ce discours là aussi peut le mettre en
danger donc on a à mon avis quelqu'un
qui est quand même acculé qui a pas
beaucoup de solutions techniques
militaires la mobilisation vous en
parliez c'est quand même une arme à
double tranchant parce que oui pour le
moment c'est les réservistes et même je
lisais les spécialistes militaires sur
les réseaux sociaux qui disent même si
on recrutait 300 000 personnes comment
on va les armer comment on va les
équiper comment on va les transporter
comment on va les mettre sur le front
avec quel encadrement etc et le dernier
point c'est qu'on a aussi à faire parce
que dans la même foulée il y a eu des
textes qui sont passés à la Douma dont
un texte particulièrement répressif sur
les désertions sur les abandons de poste
sur les gens qui quittent le front et
donc on sent aussi qu'il y a un autre
problème qui est celui de la cohérence
mentale des troupes russes qui sont
soumis à cette contre-attaque donc voilà
donc moi je trouve que
le problème c'est que quelqu'un un
régime comme celui-là est quelqu'un
comme celui-là qui est acculé d'eau au
mur effectivement on peut être inquiet
de sa capacité à
faire des gestes qui qui dépasserait la
raison Vladimir Poutine Bruno nana
d'autres choix que de céder aux factions
les plus radicales de son électorat et
de sa classe politique les
ultrasnationalistes en gros qui rigole
en conscription carrément oui oui
réclame vraiment la conscription c'est
un peu ce que disaitia alors après ce
qui se passe au Kremlin aujourd'hui
c'est un peu devenu comme à l'époque
soviétique
pour savoir exactement ce qui s'y passe
mais effectivement ce qui est clair ce
qui est clair c'est qu'il y a pas
beaucoup d'ailes gauche ou telle
démocratique et les quelques
représentants de l'aile démocratique et
ils sont en prison alors Navalny cette
exprimée aujourd'hui en estimant que
cette mobilisation ne fera que la croix
que les souffrances du peuple russe donc
dénonçant totalement évidemment cette
cette mobilisation enfin il proposition
de là où il est de faire quoi que ce
soit donc effectivement le danger c'est
qu'on pourrait finalement avoir pire que
Poutine monsieur y avait une sorte de
putsch de coup d'État à l'Intérieur de
de la machine étatique au Kremlin on
pourrait avoir pire donc évidemment
c'est pas non plus une très bonne
nouvelle et des gens encore plus
radicaux qui peut-être eux
n'hésiteraient pas à utiliser y compris
l'arme nucléaire la fuite en avant le
prend aussi la forme de ces référendum
un d'autodétermination convoqué dans
quatre régions par les pros russes et
appuyer ce matin même d'ailleurs à part
Poutine donc il endosse cette initiative
très clairement ça précipite une
escalade du conflit
parce que il est hors de question de
perdre on l'a dit souvent sur ce plateau
sur cette antenne la Russie ne va le
régime de Poutine ne peut pas perdre
parce que la défaite c'est l'humiliation
personnel et collective des militaires
autour de lui c'est malgré tout une
profonde déstabilisation de la Russie
parce que qu'est-ce qui pourrait émerger
tel cash donc tout ça donc cette défaite
impossible donc du coup on augmente
d'eau au mur les cartes de poker qu'on a
en main les référendums en étant un
puisqu'on peut construire toute une
théorie comme quoi comme si ça devenait
des territoires russes si jamais il y
avait des attaques ukrainiennes bah du
coup on pourrait utiliser des armes non
conventionnelles ou des missiles je sais
pas quoi ou des armes atomiques la
réalité c'est que je sais plus qui
disait ça une guerre on sait comment on
rentre on sait jamais comment on en sort
donc là on est dans cette phase là
d'extrême tension
avec par ailleurs des Américains qui ont
je sais pas si le discours de Biden cet
après-midi aux Nations Unies étaient
très claires le discours de Macron hier
aux Nations Unies étaient très claires
donc le camp
occidental est particulièrement solide
donc ça ne se fissure pas donc on voit
pas
décréter des faux référendums qui se
tiendront dans trois jours avec des
électeurs absents ou morts enterrés
puisqu'ils ont été tués par l'invasion
enfin on voit pas la logique à part de
jouer une carte voilà de d'escalade des
pays occidentaux qui ont déjà dit
évidemment une reconnaîtront pas les
résultats de ces référendum mais on voit
bien que du coup il change de statuts
aux yeux de la Russie si ces territoires
demain devenaient russes oui alors on
voit bien on voit bien le calcul et puis
d'abord c'est refaire un homme ça
traduit là aussi une forme de fébrilité
c'est comme s'ils avaient peur
finalement face à une espèce d'aveu en
un peu de manière implicite ou s'ils
avaient peur de perdre ces ces
territoires donc ils organisent vite
vite quand même effectivement quelques
jours des référendums pour dire la
serrure viens la Russie normative à des
fois la Russie formelle quoi ouais voilà
et ça ne ça ne veut pas dire que
peut-être dans quelques semaines ou dans
quelques mois y compris dans la
République de Daniel ou de lougans qui
sait peut-être que les forces
ukrainiennes arriveront à à pénétrer
donc en fait le temps presse et ça aussi
que ça alors
du coup les agresseurs sur le territoire
russe
Vladimir Poutine ils vont ça à son
opinion aussi mais effectivement il
pourra dire dans sa logique
qui est un peu démente par moment mais
qui est quand même une forme de logique
il pourra dire vous voyez ce sont
désormais des territoires russes donc
les Ukrainiens attaquent non plus une
partie de l'Ukraine mais une partie de
la Russie et ils sont armés par les
Occidentaux donc les Occidentaux
deviennent cette fois-ci vraiment des
cobelligérants et là c'est ce qu'il a
dit la Russie du coup quand il parle
d'intégrité territoriale bah du coup il
inclura ces nouveaux territoires dans
son intégrité territoriale et c'est là
qu'il a dit nous serons prêts à répondre
par tous les moyens après faut quand
même rester un peu calme il faut
rappeler que les Ukrainiens ont déjà
frappé en Ukraine que les Ukrainiens ont
déjà frappé au nord de carquif au delà
de la frontière russe il y a eu des
évacuations de population russe
évidemment les Russes ne font aucune
publicité sur ce qui se passe dans cette
région là particulièrement mais enfin si
on le prend à la lettre l'intérêt des
territoriale a déjà été russe a déjà été
obligé il y a vraiment la bataille des
soutiens on voit à quel point cette
guerre qui va s'installer malgré tout on
le sait maintenant on voit comment on
joue sur l'opinion européenne pénurie
hiver etc mais
la Russie aussi a un problème d'opinion
publique interne parce que tant qu'on
envoyait des minorités ethniques
allaient se faire massacrer dans le bon
basse et que c'était une guerre qui
concernait une armée professionnelle
mais entre les sanctions qui commencent
à mordre et le fait qu'on a une
perspective de mobilisation plus ou
moins générale ça veut dire que
n'importe qui peut aller
se faire massacrer dans le domaine et
puis il y a les appuis extérieurs à la
Russie parce que malgré tout le sommet
de saint-marcande c'était pas très clair
tout ça c'est les Chinois l'année
dernière on a des soucis bon c'est un
peu trop c'est pas contrôler les les
républiques centrales d'Asie centrale on
fait des démonstration de fraîcheur
demandant la paix
Erdogan me dit j'ai lu aujourd'hui que
Erdogan avait fait une déclaration pour
dire il faut trouver une solution donc
tous ces amis à lui quand il est très
puissant on voit bien jouer sa carte
parce qu'il se passe mais s'il
s'affaiblit ici son armée ça faibli si
ça puisse affaiblisse ses amis de
l'extérieur peuvent trouver que ça aussi
ça devient un petit peu gênant Bruno
Daouda
Joe Biden alors l'idée on est à l'ONU on
s'adresse à 193 états et évidemment là
ce n'est plus seulement à destination
des Occidentaux mais notamment des États
du Sud dans Emmanuel Macron hier puis
Joe by de nous aujourd'hui ont tenté de
convaincre justement ces états ce qu'on
dit jusque là non alignés qu'il s'agit
là pour le aussi eux aussi d'une
question vitale écoutée
cette guerre a pour but d'éteindre le
droit de l'Ukraine d'exister en tant
qu'État tout simplement et les droits
des Ukrainiens d'exister en tant que
peuple
ou que vous soyez ou que vous viviez
quelque soit vos croyances
cela doit glacer votre sang
à ce que disait hier Emmanuel Macron la
violation finalement de l'intégrité
territoriale ne saura être tolérée par
quelques tas de la planète ils doivent
se sentir concernés effectivement ces
pays quels qu'ils soient et et ça
explique peut-être aussi un semblant ou
un début de réveil côté indien côté
chinois alors après ça dépend ce que
j'appelle les pays non alignés il y a
quand même les pays non alignés très
fort très puissant comme l'Inde ou la
Chine et puis à tous les pays qui n'ont
pas malheureusement la même puissance
politique militaire diplomatique parfois
ont des relations économiques qui sont
dépendants
proposer à l'impérialisme ceux
d'aujourd'hui en réalité cautionne par
leur non alignement l'impérialisme russe
oui c'est l'argument un peu que qui
cherche à développer mais je pense que
pour les pays non alignés qui n'ont pas
les moyens vraiment de de se mettre en
position d'hostilité vis-à-vis de la
Russie ça va rester quand même très
compliqué je pense qu'ils vont rester
dans une très grande prudence mais je
pense que Emmanuel Macron et Joe Biden
qui parle de ça il pense effectivement
et à la Chine et à l'Inde parce que
alors effectivement au sommet de sa
marque alors n'arrêtera maudit déjà
a dit à Vladimir Poutine il lui a dit
comme ça carrément quasiment texto c'est
pas le moment de faire la guerre voilà
donc déjà le message était passé et
aujourd'hui
la Chine après l'intervention de la
lumière Poutine appelle un cessez-le-feu
via le dialogue donc on voit quand même
que là ça bouge et ce sont Emmanuel
Macron Joba Denis ils l'ont très bien
compris et Emmanuel Macron d'ailleurs je
crois citer la Chine et l'Inde donc ils
essayent de faire basculer ces grands
pays qui jusque là restez dans une
prudence très attentive on va dire et
puis ça leur permet aussi de sortir du
fait d'être accusé de représenter
uniquement le bloc occidental d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui a essayé de faire assez
habilement aujourd'hui Joe Biden puisque
en plus il était à la tribune de
l'Assemblée des Nations Unies avec son
argument en gros il a dit je suis pas le
représentant du camp occidental là je
suis à l'ONU et j'estime que tous les
pays qui avait signé la Charte de l'ONU
en 48 ils étaient très différents ils
avaient des croyances différentes des
politiques différentes etc mais il
voulait tous préserver la paix c'était
tout s'engager à ne pas envahir le
territoire d'un autre et c'est ça qui
est en train de violer la Russie c'est
pour ça que chacun devrait se sentir
concerné ça porte ce type d'argument
Ziad auprès d'Etat alors évidemment la
Chine est l'Inde ils peuvent se
permettre d'avoir une diplomation entre
guillemets autonome parce que vu les
enjeux bien sûr ils ont eux-mêmes des
intérêts mais enfin des pays moins
puissants on va dire peuvent aussi se
laisser séduire par cet argument de
principe moral non le discours a un
petit peu changé parce que on parle de
labilité des frontières de l'agression
et de l'Occupation
grosso modo une grande partie du monde
pense que les Américains sont peut-être
pas les mieux placés pour ce genre de
leçons et bon on pourrait rentrer dans
la sémantique de ce qui se passait en
Irak qu'est-ce que c'était une est-ce
que c'était une violation intégrité des
frontières etc mais bon il y a un passif
occidental qui est très difficile et
donc il y a un fond de pensée et en
particulier dans les opinions publiques
c'est moins on se mêle de cette histoire
mais on se porte et d'ailleurs on en
paye un coup économique particulièrement
violent que ça soit les prix de
l'énergie que ce soit la disruption des
transports que ça soit l'inflation
apportée que ça soit le blé que ce soit
les engrais etc et c'est pas le moment
et je pense que c'est pas le moment
aura plus d'impact que le discours
j'allais dire un petit peu moralisé qui
était la deuxième partie du discours
d'Emmanuel Macron on peut pas se
permettre une guerre en situation de
règlement climatique de l'autre point
vraiment et après je m'arrête là c'est
que encore une fois quels sont les
options russes
parce que nous on connaît les options
euros
ukrainiennes on sait ce que les
Américains veulent et que ça mais quelle
serait la situation d'une Russie en état
de défaite comment on pourrait sortir de
là et je pense que ce dossier la Russie
c'est une puissance nucléaire c'est à
notre porte de ce dossier et la question
russe est une réelle question vous
ouvrez effectivement une perspective qui
va sans doute nous occuper dans les
prochains jours peut-être les prochaines
semaines merci j'ai l'imam Merci à VOUS
Bruno Daru c'était ton va plus loin on
se retrouve dans un peu plus de 3
minutes pour un nouveau journal rester
avec nous
[Musique]